OCS Lucas Santos au cinéma Sri Prasad
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
laissez tomber mais bon héros peut-être
que je ne suis pas l'homme le plus mince j'avoue
que c'est toujours intéressant quand on
commence une nouvelle saison et vous savez  la
question est toujours de savoir par quoi commencer,
soit commencer par quelque chose de
petit pour faciliter votre chemin,
soit commencer par quelque chose d'énorme et en
finir avec cela et vous pouvez mettre cela derrière
vous dans ce cas, nous commençons par quelque chose de
vraiment énorme  accent
qui était votre erreur le seul loup vivant
et la forme que je ne dis jamais et j'adore
danser parce que vous entrez dans ce domaine
vous êtes comme si nous avions besoin d'un deuxième Walder
Frey est mort comment est-ce possible que
se passe-t-il j'étais ravi qu'ils aient fait un
plein  prothèse de tête qui correspondait à mon
visage mais je ressemble à David Bradley en tant
qu'acteur pour vraiment vous révéler et prendre
un autre visage de votre visage plutôt que de
simplement prétendre que cela a rendu les choses beaucoup
plus faciles et beaucoup plus amusantes, je suppose que c'est
l'acteur c'est juste gentil  de tirer  sur
leur propre peau vraiment et ensuite c'est
vraiment fait non coupé ça vaut le coup bien
qu'il y ait du mouvement et où vous placez
la caméra ayant peur de faire ça
et ensuite avoir Aria répéter que
sous un angle de caméra différent, on dirait
que quelque chose s'est détaché et c'est  très
efficace mais aussi cela le rend extrêmement
efficace en tant que performance de Maisie
parce qu'elle le vend si joliment
et j'aime le moment où elle se tourne vers la
femme de Walters et dit quand les gens
vous demandent ce qui s'est passé ici me dit que le
Nord se souvient que je pense que c'est une grande
ouverture  pour la saison, je pense que c'est une
excellente introduction à Aria ou d'où
elle vient d'où elle se dirige,
elle réalise sa pâleur et je suppose que oui
peut-être qu'il y a l'argument selon lequel vous
n'aviez pas à tuer toute l'armée de Frey
mais ils n'étaient pas bons  news
je ne pense pas
qu'on écoutera  ttom line
c'est ce que tout le monde va devoir affronter à la fin
c'est l'ennemi qui est
au-delà de tous les ennemis c'est comme la seule
chose que personne ne sait vraiment comment
combattre et donc la grande question est de savoir si
ces gens vont se
ressaisir sont-ils  va trouver un moyen
de combattre le grand ennemi est-ce qu'ils vont
juste se manger vivants avant que
quoi que ce soit ne se passe donc il y a de l'ambiance
cette année nous avons nous avons deux
acteurs de retour nous avons un
singleton de Ian White qui était avec nous en saison  quatre,
ce sont des maquillages similaires, mais nous avons des sortes
de petits morceaux interchangeables
et nous avons fait un
schéma de peinture légèrement différent, nous pouvons également avoir un
costume différent, donc cela crée quatre
looks différents, donc pour les blancs cette
année, nous avons décidé que nous appliquerions  jeu un
peu et weari a sculpté
énormément de zombies, leurs maquillages sont
toujours très mélangés dans le générique
parce que nous avons une énorme quantité de
cascadeurs mais nous pensions juste que nous allions changer les
choses pour améliorer  certaines des sculptures
[Musique]
ça a été une énorme chaîne de production mais
c'est quelque chose que nous avons pu utiliser quelques
taupes existantes et ensuite faire un tas de
nouvelles choses aussi
[Musique]
jolie chanson que je n'avais jamais eue avant c'est une
nouvelle  et Sharons a eu une belle
voix et nous savions qu'il était fan de la
série et nous savions que Maisy était obsédée
par lui, alors nous avons toujours pensé que ce
serait amusant d'essayer de le faire entrer dans une
scène labyrinthique à un moment donné. J'ai d'abord eu la
scène  puis j'ai vu que j'étais un soldat Lancer
et c'était incroyable j'ai juste supposé que nous serions
tous tués dans les impôts Je ne veux pas de
céréales que vous ne volez pas que nous
offrons allez ça va être une
journée froide juste une belle  moment pour elle de vraiment
profiter de la compagnie humaine sans mensonges ni
ruse, je pense que le thème sous-jacent est
que, comme dans toute guerre, les soldats ne sont que des
personnes et nous sommes de jeunes garçons, il
adore vraiment entendre leurs histoires et
retrouver un peu de normalité et je
pense  elle réalise en quelque sorte qu'elle peut
juste se détendre en le laissant  r garder de la
nourriture et faire des blagues alors
pourquoi une gentille fille se dirige-t-elle seule vers
King's Landing Je vais tuer la
reine et ensuite - j'ai compris
qu'est-ce que nous attendions toute notre
vie en train de tirer  cette scène de Map Room
était c'était une très grande chose et
des conversations très approfondies avec Lena et
Nikolai à propos du fait que tu avais peur de moi
devrais-je penser
qu'il y a un grand besoin de
vengeance pour ses ennemis au sud,
c'est comme si elle avait besoin de tout mettre
dormir qui lui cause de la douleur mr.  le nord,
elle est maintenant juste de ce
chemin très concentré vers la domination du monde
et bien sûr nous présentons
tout cela et vous avez dit qui est dans cette
cour dans le Keith rouge où il y a
une carte peinte à la main bien sûr vous voulez
montrer cet incroyable  chose et a également une
grande valeur métaphorique là-bas, elle
parcourt le monde connu en
pensant à le gouverner, donc vous voulez en quelque sorte
rendre justice à cet
aspect également, nous avons pensé qu'une carte peinte sur
le sol qui semblait être un bon  l'idée que les
ennemis partout étaient entourés de
traîtres, nous savions que la tache Jim car le
graphiste créerait
quelque chose d'incroyable et il a travaillé si dur
dessus que nous voulions avoir une allusion à
la séquence de titre d'ouverture et cela
signifiait simplement utiliser une partie du lettrage certains
de  les images et trouver de bonnes
couleurs, puis les travailler essentiellement
sur un ordinateur, puis nous avions une image que
nous pouvions imprimer et qui était de la bonne
taille latitude cèdre médiéval dr  des ailes de
villes beaucoup de lettrage beaucoup de
conversation avec le designer, en
particulier
deux gars qui entrent, ils reviendraient et
Greg Winters qui est venu
peindre l'image que j'ai conçue sur
la grippe l'homme qui est fermement mais
poliment renvoyé à la  le début de
la scène par Jamie Lannister est en effet
Jim stains qui a conçu et créé la
carte pour commencer Je ne pense
pas qu'être à genoux aussi humble
était aussi amusant qu'il le
pensait mais j'ai bien fait là-bas
Je pense que c'est amusant de voir Sam et son
nouvel environnement où nous devons vraiment
venir ici dans le genre de tour de la
connaissance pour apprendre les secrets du
monde connu et inconnu et il est vraiment
juste vous connaissez un rouage dans cette machine
Sam passe un temps assez misérable et ses
rêves ne correspondent pas à la réalité, nous
ne nous appuyons pas souvent sur le montage dans la
série, en partie parce que les montages pour bien
faire prennent beaucoup de temps et beaucoup de
ressources quand il est venu nous voir à un
point elle s  aide, nous avons trois
jours et demi de calendrier pour ce montage, il
a fallu beaucoup de temps pour tourner ce qui est peut-être un
montage de deux minutes, vous savez la fin
où nous avons coupé la scène ensemble, c'était
hilarant
[Musique
] revenir à un endroit qui  vous a créé
et c'était le début de vous et
la fin de votre famille est une sorte d'épopée
Danny rentrant à la maison est une
séquence vraiment intéressante et je pense que ce qui
était vraiment adorable, c'était de le faire pour
Game of Thrones et de faire une séquence
comme ça vous pouvez  faites vraiment de l'improvisation comme
si vous alliez vraiment prendre votre temps avec
ça, vous pouvez vraiment lui donner son dû comme un
vrai moment parce qu'il n'y a pas de dialogue,
cela donne plus de poids à Amelia qui
fait tout cela avec son visage et ses
actions et son mouvement  met beaucoup
de poids sur le département artistique parce que
l'endroit lui-même est vraiment l'autre
personnage principal,
l'espace doit être quelque chose que
Daenerys se sent très lié à l'endroit où
tout ce dont elle a entendu parler est
soudainement en quelque sorte devant elle
[Musique]
J'étais passionnant à faire dans des endroits où
nous avons tourné en Espagne car ils étaient absolument
incroyablement beaux, nous devions trouver un
endroit qui avait un certain poids et une certaine
puissance et quand nous sommes arrivés à la
plage de Sumaya, les formations géologiques
là-bas sont si uniques et  si spéciaux et
si intéressants qu'ils ont un
poids que je pense qu'aucun de nous ne pourrait
ignorer en fait assez souvent, nous devons
diviser l'emplacement pour la même scène, le
résultat final a été que nous avons décidé que nous pouvions
faire la plupart de ce que nous voulions faire dans  deux
endroits répartis entre l'Espagne et
l'Irlande du Nord, l'arrivée est tournée à
Zumaya,
vous montez ensuite sur la plate-forme, montez
un escalier
sur scène ici et facturez plus rapidement
, puis une fois qu'elle franchit ces
portes ici, vous la reprenez à
San  Juan où elle monte les marches
du château
et ces endroits ensemble ont informé
pour moi toute la conception Dragonstone
et tout est venu de ces
formations rocheuses vraiment uniques qui sont si
spéciales et ver  y unique juste pour cette
partie du monde les portes de
Dragonstone ça va probablement être
filmé pendant environ 30 secondes mais tellement de
détails et de travail ont été investis dans cet ensemble deux
têtes de dragon géantes ont été sculptées par une
équipe de sculpteurs de hiboux avec les plus belles grandes
portes massives  qui ont été conçus et
construits ici
les endroits en Espagne vous aviez cette
formation rocheuse très forte que le restaurant a
commencé à apprendre et nous avons pu
apporter ces belles
formations géologiques dans ces couloirs latéraux nous
avons dû utiliser les rochers de l'endroit où
nous avons envoyé une équipe  de plâtre Espagne, ils ont
pris du grès de compression et à partir de
ceux-ci, nous avons créé des moules et nous avons utilisé ces
formes rocheuses pour créer les formes des
couloirs de la grotte, il y a ce genre
de voyage géologique physique que nous
avons pu concevoir et qui a ensuite
abouti au trône  pièce où nous
avons dû créer comme une nouvelle architecture
c'est beaucoup de travail c'était très très
laborieux
[Musique]
pour lui
dramatiquement avant tout Dr  agonstone
avait bien sûr été établi au cours des
saisons précédentes avant mon arrivée, nous avions donc la
salle des cartes de Dragonstone, donc elle était déjà
établie comme un espace semblable à une grotte
, donc je voulais que cet ensemble
commence en quelque sorte dans la grotte et en sorte
puis nous  ont pu apporter ces
belles formations géologiques sur ce
trône,
vous savez le trône de pierre de dragon qui, je
pense, est une sorte
de déclaration vraiment puissante,
les seules instructions que nous lui avons données étaient
qu'il devrait être assez imposant et
intimidant et que le trône
serait  gravé sur le rocher et c'est tout ce
que nous lui avons donné, puis elle est allée
en enfer avec cette
[musique]
la première fois que nous l'avons vu tout éclairé pour une
scène assez dramatique pendant que nous la
construisions, les gens
parcouraient cet ensemble  et ils auraient l'impression que je
me sens très mal à l'aise ici, ce n'est pas une
pièce où je veux passer beaucoup de temps,
donc c'était une nouvelle approche d'une salle d'audience
qui n'accueillait pas les
gens.  anguille
mal à l'aise et intimidée ouais je pense que c'est
peut-être le meilleur décor que nous ayons jamais
construit c'était vraiment impressionnant nous avions
hâte de le tourner la salle d'audience est
incroyable l'un des décors les plus stupéfiants dans
lesquels j'ai eu le privilège d'
être  à chaque instant de ce voyage
du navire à l'endroit où
elle va se tenir debout et planifier sa
conquête, il y a une saveur différente pour
chacun de ces modèles et nous réalisons que
cet endroit où elle est née, il y
avait toute la culture là-bas, ce monde entier
là-bas et  vous en avez un vrai goût et
avec un caractère unique et le retour à la
maison était vraiment très dramatique
allons-nous commencer
[Musique]
OCS visit fan you miss
[Music]